شخصيه سندباد الشهيره ذاك البحار الذي
يهوى الابحار والمغامرات تعتبر من اهم
شخصيات كتاب الف ليله وليله التي الهمت
قصته الاعمال السينمائيه والروائيه سواء
للاطفال او حتى للكبار
وبعد اعتماده شعار كاس الخليج نظرا
لارتباط البصره وشواطئها برحلات السندباد
الاسطوريه مثير الجدل والخلاف حول اصله هو
تعدد الاقوال عن اصل شخصيه سندباد وفجاه
تحول البحر الاسطوري الى ازمه سياسيه
مع اعتراض ايران التي قالت ان السندباد
فارسي وليس عربي وذلك على لسان اتحادها
لكره القدم الذي اعترض على العراق عندما
استخدمه كتميمه لكاس الخليج العربي
وفي ما يرى اخرون ان السندباد اصل الهنديه
فسمه مكون من مقطعين هنديين هما سنه اباد
ومعناهما البطل او زعيم نهر السند تبحر
احتمالات اخرى صوب مدينه صحار
العاصمه القديمه لعمان كمطن اصلي للسندباد
حيث كانت حين ذاك منطلقا مهما للرحلات
البحريه نحو الصين الامر الذي عزل لدى
كثيرين وخصوصا اهل عمان فرضيه انتماء
سندباد لارضهم على كل حال يستمر التنقيب
عن اصل سندباد على اعتبار ولو جزئيا
لشخصيه واقعيه